[Music]
that's the sound of real birds tweeting
in the morning
[Music]
drives having in store for you this week
[Music]
[Applause]
this story begins a week ago on Friday
just off that I had a breakthrough idea
I ordered some then began to pack my
bags this was my biggest idea yet
something I knew that would create the
best film I've ever made so I flew to
London that night
Odyssey was confident in knowing that
the film would just happen my others I
arrived to slip the plane ride off and
took to the streets to seek some
inspiration
but something was wrong I had this
overwhelming sensation of blank
nothingness like my brain couldn't think
[Music]
I took to Twitter to meet up with
another creative and ended up having a
chat with the sky Davis who's wise
beyond his years a lot of people have
tried make you great oh you're not a
painter don't do that say why he says
the company says I can't be a painter it
sparked an idea to go do this if he says
he can't man he says he can't just
smacking it but still that didn't know
the next morning I took a bus and in a
cab to a place called Burnie
and my phone is based now to give you
some context have you ever seen the TV
show crossroads well she's lying in
shape that's Birmingham I got to my
hotel and idea just fall flat did
meaningless how could something that
inspired me to fly to the UK spend the
time money and excitement on just
disappear I sat there in the middle of
the night in my boxers trying to write
something anything I recorded this
because I thought I'd have some creative
breakthrough caught on camera it never
happened
[Music]
this is where the story gets interesting
I was broken not like emotionally that
was the problem
I was just incapable of feeling anything
gave up i sat in the airports on my way
back to New York scrolling through old
photos on my phone and then realized
there was something I needed to go and
see the only thing that might possibly
bring me back to thinking clearly again
so I jumped on a bus from 8th grade to
get got on a small plane and arrived in
a quiet town in Austria called Zeile
with my camera and shoes that were not
made for the mountains to stay with
Garvey and Klaus
okay let's pause here for a sec
obviously they don't chase like the
stalee but they were excited to see me
and I told them I was making a phone I
woke up early the next morning by the
sound of the birds and took to the
mountains I knew I had a really far way
to hike and in these shoes wouldn't be
easy I had to do this alone
[Music]
this is very vague rills proper
wildlings
[Music]
[Music]
I really don't want these firms to be
this deep you know Butler said this
place where I'm sitting right now is is
where everything began this is the
reason I came to Austria this is where
that first photo of me snowboarding was
taken which going back home and wanting
to start surfing and surfing gave me the
opportunity to be able to buy my first
camera which gave me the opportunity to
start making films and like I think that
for me like it's so important to stick
to like my path you know as a filmmaker
I can say the last thing I wanna do is
make these films bleak but I have to be
honest on this channel if this is gonna
work like I can't make a film about
being stoked and happy and everything
when I'm I'm starting to like lose sight
of
the kinds of foams that I should be
making and like that's where I found
myself in before I decided to come onto
YouTube and I was stuck in advertising
and I was just getting so depressed you
know at home I'm so grateful that I can
be able to make these films and so what
if people watch me crying not like this
is me and me being honest like coming
here and sitting here is been probably
the most memorable sentimental
experience I promise
a lot of happy films are gonna come out
of this experience I'm gonna spend the
rest of the day just sitting here and
chatting
[Music]
I spend three hours there staring at the
sky can I hit it to a nearby river which
I hadn't realized yet is created from
the melting ice on the nearby mountains
[Applause]
it was literally freezing as I said that
spins all my YouTube ad revenue and
attended the most luxurious spa in all
of Austria called the SH White's when in
Austria one has to go stock
[Music]
it's okay to be done I think this new
world tells you that you shouldn't be
able to feel like [ __ ] that you
shouldn't take a break everything is
moving so fast you know
I read that that's a bunch of [ __ ]
like I almost had a fool bloody mental
breakdown at the age of 28 because I
couldn't get my lost YouTube phone right
I'm gonna stop living so seriously I'm
gonna start creating my own rules like
the ones that made me happy you know for
us what's the point
apologies for the native bird it is of
my utmost importance to be here for you
we continue I will always give that by
everything if you don't hear from me or
see me it's because I'm working my ass
off somewhere trying to make the best
form possible other than that I'll see
you in a couple of days from any tablet
thank you for understanding I made it I
made it home back on it tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]